Uh, dreaming.
Let's go. I'm feeling the pressure today.
That was cool. What just happened? Oh my God.
Welcome to song lab.
The show where our talented song lab producers get paired up with musicians and
have only two hours to create an original song.
The most voted song will be the winner and the team will get a cash prize.
Get ready for song.
[Inaudible].
Hi everyone. We have here with us. Our amazing song left producers.
What's up everyone. My name is Mikayla. My artist's name is dear evergreen.
Hey guys. My name is Simon.
I'm a producer from Toronto Canada. Today.
We brought two musicians from two very different genres.
You said you don't want to go that way. I'm not going to go into my mouth. Hey,
what's going on guys? My name is [inaudible]. I am a rapper. I grew up
studying battle rap. I was very focused on my punchlines of ours.
More than anything else. You're still cool.
Hi, my name is Nick Smith and I'm a pop artist and song writer.
And I love finding that balance between a song that's really deep,
but at the same time, it's really easy to listen to.
Now you did decide to what the teams are going to be for today. Song battle.
Is in my throat.
Get ready.
And the teams are Lex you're on team Simon and
Maggie team. Evergreen.
We have a specific theme for today's song battle. The theme is.
Okay.
That's a tough subject to write a song.
I don't have much experience with that one.
I'm not going to talk about how I'm going to take it.
[Inaudible].
We asked our audience and followers for word suggestions based on the theme of
death. All right, team Simon,
three words for your team's lyrics are time gone and
heal.
And the three words for your team's lyrics are comfort,
pain and fear. Absolutely.
Each team will have two hours to create an original song with the team of
debt and use the selected three words in your lyrics given by our followers.
I hope you all vibe with each other and made the best song wins.
Seriously. Are we going to do hip hop? We're going to go all out.
We're going to go, you know, like with.
The death theme, I'm not thinking like sadness,
I'm thinking like I'm killing my competition. Like rappers,
like I'm telling them that type of debt.
We just literally do something that's like see
she to at her to,
like the most basic progression you've ever heard.
Honestly, like if we're going for like pop, let's go for a pop.
Let's go for pop.
Jump it.
Awesome. I love that.
I kind of liked that one. Yeah.
I'm going to loop at two minutes. Have fun. Is this a, is this a number one?
Hit song on a billboard. It's up to you. That's not.
So it's all on me now. That's what you're saying. Exactly. There we go.
Sometimes I get a buzz in the air. Oh no, I lost my stuff.
Oh no. If you open it back up,
it won't be like auto save to the last. Probably not.
That's the first time I saw that air, I'm saving every six seconds now.
Lyrica, uh,
death as a metaphor for like an ending relationship.
I feel like that's so it's a ball.
We can use a lot of fun metaphors and like cliche is, and it'll be easy.
It really works for me.
Great.
Did we lose her?
My computer just crashed. Um, God,
this is the worst timing.
Yeah. And the me are my enemies. Want me dead? That's funny.
I like starting it off with the hook. Like,
like on some debate they just call me like, Oh, for sure. Enemies.
I trust. I trust you. I trust your, um, your artistry. Okay. Okay.
Enemies.
Enemies will be dead. Funny.
Yeah. Maybe just this stuff at the beginning. Right. And then me. So my.
Enemies would be dead funny.
Yeah. So hard. All right. Cool. I'm really excited for this one.
My back, my computer,
like fully crashed that's way. Oh my gosh.
I, yeah, I hope it's okay. Yeah, me too.
Um.
And this just starts on the one. Yeah.
Oh, wait, wait. It doesn't. Maybe doesn't start on the one.
That was cool, but just happened. That was that. Wasn't what I wrote.
Finished sleep, but I'm killing dreams and stuff.
I'm like blanking right now, but I got this. I got I doing like, Oh,
you know what? Um, I'm like psyching myself out.
But I think that once I get like a rhyme scheme, I'll be able to like, go,
go for, okay. I have to do like funeral lines.
I have to do like death lines and trying to think like, yeah. Right.
But I want to get this flow down first and then work on my next flight to be
stressful though. Isn't it look at you. I know I'm getting stressed out.
I swear. It's not distressful to work with me on a normal shirt.
It's not actually making something fires.
What do you feel about a vocoder? Chorus moment.
Love it. Awesome.
You killed it all.
Oh, wasn't it fun?
That's perfect. Yeah. Literally that gives me so much inspiration, so, okay.
[Inaudible] killed it.
Like so stripped out just like the chords and like the vocoder.
Yeah, totally. Okay. Got this.
Oh, team evergreen. Hi team Simon. Sorry.
We're a challenge. Isn't it?
Today's challenge is the household objects challenge.
Our followers have suggested different household objects and your team must find
record and use. The sounds made from that object in your song,
your team must use a zipper for today's challenge.
Your team must use a blender for today's challenge.
I don't have, I do have a blender.
All right. Good luck guys. Thank you. Cool.
Record one. That's slow. And then one that's like fast.
Cause what I'm going to do is turn into a percussive element.
Zipper jeans. Oh, jacket, easy a jacket.
Let me go grab the blender real quick.
Can't get the zipper. Okay.
I'm sending the zipper to now tell me this anymore.
It's like it's right here.
Yeah. I love it. It's like perfect.
You killed it.
The most stressful thing I've ever. God,
my computer crashed again.
Camera's on the one on down. I know. I know. I know. All right,
yo. Yeah, we do. I got to go. All right. Go.
Okay. I'm back. My computer crashed again. I'm going to attract some harmonies.
You catch it?
Yeah. Killed it.
You killed it. Oh, all right. Let's go. It sees this can pick it up the coat.
I'm sorry. I'm abuse. I mean, sorry. Excuse my language,
Uber over. Oh my gosh. I'm getting,
we can do this. Picking up my cohort. I'm an Uber or I compensate them.
What she's feeling, whereas him asleep, lying on me, but the truth parts killer.
Right. But then I said as parts to Brazil who the young and maneuver. Oh, sorry.
Pick up your new arm. Cause I've been to take since the grim abuser. Cool.
That's going to have to be good enough.
I need to like remember to breathe.
Oh dude. Comfort. Yeah.
Yes. Yes.
Oh, I forgot to use the zipper. Hold on. Okay. All right. Oh,
let's get that going.
I'm feeling the pressure today for sure. I'm really feeling.
Oh my God.
I always say the first words before I come in. Oh, why do you do that?
It just helps me kind of gain the same payment.
So I make sure I'm kind of body's about the seasons. My cohort. I'm like,
Ooh girl, her competition.
I got scared. Oh no. Make sure you saving. I don't
know what you're doing.
Oh my God. This is crazy.
Swan song, right? Yeah. So I was on that. Okay.
It's like flappy song for like how sad, depressing.
You. The truth.
You are definitely the true quickest mastering you've ever seen in your life.
Love it. What do you wanna call it?
Good. It's so good. It's an edit that like it didn't even listen to, so.
That first hour I could not think of anything. And then it finally came to me.
What? I was getting a blender. The blender got blended that got me.
It gave me inspiration.
Well, I feel like we did really well given everything for this track,
it was all about making her voice pop shot.
The song we made is a bit short,
but there's a clear sense of structure and we kind of wrapped it up in a ribbon.
So it's this nice, concise little sock. I hope that when people hear the song,
they don't think it was something that was rushed.
And then it sounds like a really song.
Enjoy your session. Sure. Yeah. Okay.
All right. Hi everyone. Welcome back.
I hope both teams were able to get everything done in two hours.
Let's now hear team every.
Oh no. I love that back on vocals. Beautiful.
Oh my God.
Oh
God. Why?
This sounds so great.
Thank you.
Have such a nice voice. Thank you. Beautiful voice feels like,
like a feather is tickling my ear or something. As soon as I heard Meg's voice,
I knew that that's going to be a great pairing with a dear Evergreen's
production. And it was a mix. Vocals were gorgeous. And um,
dear evergreens production was fantastic. So.
Like shouts out to them. Whoa,
enemies are my enemies. Want me dead funny?
And a G really in and all of these heads running and it deems gone. Tell me,
get to that bread. Money.
Enemies are, my enemies will be dead. As funny.
My inner game has gone. Somehow. They smoked us,
has been asleep and I'm killing dreams and stent and haunting all my enemies.
When me, dad
[inaudible] me to get Ben. Cause they going to be gone by Tom I'm here.
Then John fall, spring, summer, winter,
I find the bodies about the seasons picking up my cohort. I'm like, Ooh, Ooh,
[inaudible] pick up your new arm because I'm going to take lives on abuse or a
mass funeral row. You won't get that.
Still get to live frog and don't matter what you are. Yeah.
And it means that my enemies will be dead as funny. And
[inaudible] they get to that breath. They finish asleep,
but I'm killing dreams instead that hunting hole.
Holy like, wow, like, Whoa,
your vocals are insane.
Sound like literally a superstar. I'm Brian.
Dream team right there.
So I think maybe we need to work on a project.
[inaudible] that was crazy good.
Like from the first like two seconds, I knew like, okay,
this is a really good song.
You could just tell from their energy and from the music that they played,
that like these two were like, meant to collaborate together.
This is going to be a hard one. They're so different.
Well, we've posted the songs online for voting and people already picking their
favorite track as we speak.
And soon we're going to find out which team is going to win today.
Honestly, you do think your team is going to win. This one is really tough.
Our songs are completely completely.
So I'm, I'm convinced we're not winning,
which is fine because I'm still very proud of the work that we did.
I'm proud of myself, but I definitely think their song. It was like, cool.
I was super nervous about this experience.
And so the idea of my team winning would kind of make me feel a lot better as a
writer.
How the results with me, it was very, very close.
Okay. Very close. But there can only be one winner.
Look, everyone's so tense. The winning song for today,
song lab is head hunting from team Simon and
means of my enemies.
Now we have to make an AP.
Exactly. I'm really happy with everything to be honest.
Like I think it all went really well. I'm proud of myself. I think they totally,
totally deserve to win. They absolutely.
That's a big sigh of relief. Just big,
massive weight off my shoulders now, you know, it's definitely,
obviously it's not about winning, but it's nice to finally get a win for once.
Oh, my biggest takeaway is, uh,
I think I would say like not underestimate myself. Um, yeah,
doing that in two hours was kind of crazy.
And the fact that I was able to do it is pretty great.
Simon absolutely killed it and I would love to work with him in the future.
So siren, when you, when you hear this, I want to work with you, you killed it.
And I think that collectively as a group and within two hours,
I think we did a pretty good job.
I hope you enjoyed that episode of song lab. If you liked it,
hit the light button, share this video with your friends.
And if you want to see other battle of genres,
please comment below what genres you want to see at song lab.
These songs are fire. If you liked them,
make sure to click on the link below so you can listen to them on Spotify and
other streaming services. Thank you so much again. And until next time.